[Musica]
[Applauso]
allora beh buona sera a tutti tanto e
ringrazio il team per avermi dato
l'opportunità di raccontarmi questa sera
premetto che è la prima volta che parlo
da vice a queste tante persone quindi
libero capiate l'agitazione definizione
io sono rino ho 19 anni e prima di
spiegarvi come mai alla gamba tabella
della vostra dobbiamo fare quanto in
questo indietro allora ho avuto
un'infanzia per certo non mi è mancato
niente nonostante sia cresciuta da sola
quella mia madre e ne sono andate grande
ma come ormai sappiamo nella vita niente
certo così mia madre si ammalò inizia ad
essere a finte questo successe quando io
alle volte ufficiali quindi per un
adolescente sicuramente è un motivo di
sconforto e ho iniziato
provate
[Applauso]
[Musica]
grazie allora il mio padre ci siamo
trasferiti montagne sono cresciuta a
milano in una grande città siamo andati
in un paesino piccolino appunto mia
madre ha iniziato ad essere assente nei
miei confronti
e allora deciso di andare a vivere da
mio padre che non frequentavo e non ho
mai frequentato e andando dal mio padre
ci siamo resi conto che comunque sia
l'assenza non poteva essere superata da
un giorno all'altro e a gennaio 2017 ho
avuto un crollo psicologico è stato un
periodo fortissimo per me pensavo di non
avere una mia giusta d'uscita io mi sono
resa conto di quanto la mente umana sia
importante dopo questo periodo
mio padre mi ha portato al mare a
montone dove io ho iniziato ad avere una
vita normale
una vita che tutti gli adolescenti
svolgono quindi frequentavo bravi
ragazzi avevo degli orari abbiamo delle
regole
ho conosciuto un ragazzo con la testa
sulle spalle e quello che abbiamo
iniziato a spostarci in motorino
eravamo al mare io mi sentivo libera e
dichiarata
iniziamo stare bene fino a che una sera
io stavo la malattia le mie ha detto che
andava a lavorare a cannes e quindi
sarei rimasta lì
da sola mio padre realizza e io abbiamo
detto al mio papà che sarei stata con la
sua compagna di razza è così
usciamo andiamo a maggiore fuori e
andiamo a dolceacqua chiama un paesino
nell'entroterra lingue questo paesino
che ricordava tantissimo il paese dove
avevo vissuto con mia madre in montagna
e lì ho iniziato a pensare capita
ti sei forse è bruciata gli anni
migliori e così ho detto ai 17 anni
aiuta la vita davanti e poi recuperare
ti può dare un'altra possibilità quella
sera tornando a casa gli era sorta nei
pensieri
stavo guardando per terra la strada e
senza il botto di una moto che arriva
dall'altra parte della carreggiata
questa moto si scontra con la nostra e
inizia a pensare ok non fosse al quale
scooter le dinamiche di un incidente
deve andare a casa perché insomma in
casa beckham era sola in realtà stavo
già rotolando ho fatto per fermare un
con tutta la forza possibile che avevo
quando ho fatto per alzarmi mi sono resa
conto che in realtà sarebbe dovuta
rimanere
allora perché era morto purtroppo meno
le ha tranciato tutti e desideri così si
dice che quando stai per morire
vedi tutta la vita quest'arte da mamma
realtà non è vero che ho visto tutto
quello che ancora devo fare e non può
essere che finita qua così assolutamente
no così il dolore l'adrenalina e tutto
quanto hanno fatto sì che io non perde
si sentì aspettato l'ambulanza 40 minuti
e al risveglio c'era tutta la mia
famiglia io purtroppo e per fortuna da
una parte sapevo cosa fosse successo
sapevo che non la vede e non ci sono
voluti due giorni per riprendermi avesse
piangevamo tutti quanti ho cercato di
mantenere il sorriso più che altro per
le persone che mi circondavano perché è
stata una situazione come potete
immaginare difficilissima ma in quel
momento mi sentivo di dare la forza agli
altri più che il contrario che dopo
appunto due o tre giorni ho ricominciato
mi sono riposte stato del mio telefono e
ho iniziato a farmi sempre mettere foto
su instagram insomma a fare la anche la
subito sulle altri di a rotelle e dopo
qualche giorno di uscita sorella mi ha
mostrato paolantoni chiama modella
brasiliana e lei ha una protesi
glitterata fittissima e il mio sogno è
sempre stato quello di fare la modella o
comunque sia di entrare a far parte
lo spettacolo come intenso magari la
maggior parte delle ragazze e ovviamente
mi sono battuto ho pensato quando ma
entro fare la modella senza un pezzo di
gamba tra l'altro quelli l'hanno fatto
dei casting per le agenzie visto che
avrebbe compiuto 18 anni a novembre e
dopo qualche giorno viene un ospedale
ancora chiamato dell'agenzia che dice se
fermi presa e di concordate per mi
spiace ma io e lui non mi fanno nota al
corpo allora altri video che
intraprenderà le altre strade però mi
piace assolutamente no a questo mio
sogno non mi interessa appena paul
calcio non piaccio sicuramente troverò
qualcuno che mi accetterà e anche mi
vorrai tocco mente così come sono perché
prima avevo bellissimo stacco di gambe
bene o no una forza sangue quindi niente
ho passato due mesi in ospedale tra
riabilitazione ricovero è sempre
quest'anno con tutti ultimi progressi e
sono passata da un momento in cui erano
i miei amici a darmi la forza di armi
pravo con ciro questi vai avanti momenti
in cui erano loro
termini ma io ti seguo guardato le tue
storie e mi stimi per forza allora ho
deciso di sfruttare questa situazione a
mio vantaggio pensato ok le altre
modelle hanno due gambe però appunto io
ho mio carattere le mie debolezze le
cicatrici dovevo farsi assolutamente che
questo ben carne a favore così pian
piano primaria acquistato appunto una
mobilità la fiducia in me stessa
anche perché ammetto non è stato non è
stato per niente facile magari mostrarmi
fin da subito però deciso di non
coprirmi mai anzi mi ricordo di un padre
quando fanno correre un ospedale su
diete una copertina da mettere sulla
sedia rotelle ancora non angola protesi
e mi diceva spendiamoli strano che
magari gli spaventi bambini può essere
maleducazione io mi sono rifiutato
subito perché questo non è un problema
io non lo risolverà mai frattempo così
se non lo accetto io come possono
accettarlo gli altri perché quando sei
in questa situazione ci si rende conto
che sono io a dover mettere voi anno
prima con la mia disabilità
detto ciò qualche mese dopo è arrivato
nel contratto con un'agenzia di moda
inclusiva con tratta per la maggior
parte
in carrozzina piuttosto che a vantati e
sempre qualche misero la possibilità e
l'onore invece dichiara terrà ieri mi ha
fatto qualche storia e da lingue
provvidenza che ha mai iniziato a salire
e ad oggi sono un influencer modella e
ho tanti altri suoni ma ho trovato un
poco tempo fa fare snowboard
penso anche che sperano che voglio
sapere se che sono pure un atleta è
quello che voglio dire oggi è che per
quanto la vita possa essere difficile
come dicevo prima la mente umana è
importantissimo al seno ci diciamo di
essere positivi forti e sereni la vita
ci sarà questo quindi non dobbiamo mai
lasciare con i venturieri mm di
spiacevole unici limiti i limiti
esistono per essere superati stanno
nella nostra testa
noi ci crediamo gli invincibili perché
il fatto che siamo tutti
[Applauso]